okay well for people who are joining
this livestream this is a continuing
discussion about quantum computing
capabilities for from language and we
have a preliminary implementation of
lots of things here and I guess we're
about to look at them so should we start
off with quantum discrete state so does
this have examples and things as well
yes oh boy okay so okay so what about a
more sophisticated version of this let's
see so what is this thing that was funky
yes so we had talked about ways to
represent the quantum states graphically
and in order to encode the phase and
amplitude information this was the
simplest way that we could come up with
okay well I think that's a that's a
separate words that's so unbelievably
much space around them around that so
that's something that I was just
prototyping and we could have I could
take another look at it or all right
okay fine but let's not let's not obsess
about that yet okay
so boy there's a lot of stuff here okay
nice what where should I start looking
to start seeing a more complete example
it's quantum circuit the place to go
quantum circuit and quantum operation
will have some other things but then the
documentation here looks rather
incomplete oh I see it doesn't have
anything for these other ones either
okay so okay let's look at your quantum
discrete state first of all so what
you've got but that's quantum object
Aero values is that right so that's why
one arrow and then what it is yep the
concept and we implemented the summer
box for each thing so now you can get
different you can extract properties
about the quantum state right um I guess
you're here the state is the state the
state doesn't assume values right so
that's that's one thing potentially we
might want to call this quantum discrete
system and then that system takes on
States okay I understand what you mean
my god okay granted this great state I
think it doesn't yield anything it
represents something and the state is
the state there's not more to be said
it's the end of the story like the world
to what it's supposed to what is written
here that thinks assume values in the
state so this is some sort of state
expressed in some basis of states I know
but this is not what did currently says
okay hold on second so there are a bunch
of objects you know three wires or
something and these are assumed to be
the those are assumed to be some kind of
outer product of things is that right I
mean y1 y2 y3 are all it intended to be
in the in this case here these are
independent quantum objects is that true
or not so yeah when you write them
separately like that then they're
assumed to be independent quantum
objects and the the Kronecker product is
taken but then in the second example you
have state mm-hmm the second example is
some as a something we're they're not
just product you could have entangled
them objects right so this case you mean
this this case here right well those are
the quantum objects and the values
somehow represent some entangled thing
exactly and I don't understand what this
is now here so the product is if you
happen if you already generated quantum
states and there's examples of all these
things below okay
you already generated quantum states for
like wire one you had one quantum state
and YRT doing different one you could
just you could use that constructor to
take to make the product state I'm
confused here what
so women this why is there okay this
trace thing here I don't understand this
because what we've got here is a case in
which we've got quantum object goes to
values and now we've got this thing
product for example which is sort of
putting standing in the place of a
quantum object it's not a quantum object
what is it so this is what we so we
could represent this as an external
product of previously specified quantum
states which is that to save some
symbols here for the moment we are
putting this inside but you can see this
has a quantum state product and then
though there's an option to if you want
to be consistent about the location
there is you can do quantum state a
discrete state of and then in the first
are the like the product or mixture or
trace you could say quantum objects then
arrow and then you can have the stuff
that you've had in that's the input in
the first and second examples so that's
just another constructor but if you
don't put a constructor then assumes
that it's just quantum objects I didn't
quite understand that I mean in but let
me let me just try to get a sense here
of what the right-hand side what the
values here can be so what does this
mean that means that you were taking
some system wire one which is a qubit
and you're putting it in the zero
computational basis state okay so but
we've got several different things
running around here so this is the heck
is this now so this is saying we've got
three quantum objects all of which are
seem to be qubits and unless otherwise
specified and they're put in the
register in the computational basis for
eight of this you know zero through
seven
okay so
let's see and so that word like basis
state would just be
represented by some state vector here is
that the idea which in this case I don't
quite understand this there's a basis
state the difference there is if you
want it if you were to have two wires
and so you had wire 1 , wire 2 goes to
basis state then and you put in and we'd
be after the 0 you would put in another
0 or 1 and so you're basically
specifying the basis for each of the
wires individually whereas for register
why is it why is it 0 1 why is that the
right um representation so if I say if I
said here sort of W 1 comma W 2 it goes
to basis state 0 0 is that right yep ok
now explain this to me this is why is it
0 oh I see that that's because it's it's
a it's thought of as a qubit and
kulick001 right exactly
we're working in this canonical
computational basis where 0 1 what
happens if I use return false instead do
we accept those I can easily change it
so that we do accept those as well it
seems useful I mean ok so now this that
is these are labeled with 1 1 1 0 0 1 0
0 is that right so you can actually if
you just do the % and then say bassists
cancer I think it's basis states
something like that
you an ordered list of what the bases
are that we're using those okay a little
bit funky I mean that is that those are
strings is kind of funky because you
need we need more information what we're
specifying about quantum states has a
little bit more information than just
putting 0 0 or 0 1 because we could be
working in any basis we could be working
with Q traits we had we don't know you
know what the quantum objects are that
we're working with if we just specify
you know as your or a one like that but
this is just telling you what each entry
in our state vector corresponds to in
this combined basis look I think you
should call it something like basis
labels or something so if you if you put
in try basis labels right now I need to
go up to Center 838 what does that mean
that's saying that the first element is
corresponds to the bassists of wire 1
and the second element in the basis
states were response to the basis of
white or two okay well I look I think
that getting this out is useful but I
don't think as Michael says it seems to
me that the basis states are whatever
the representation of that state 0 0 0 1
etc is or am i confused here well there
is an issue here which is that we are
expressing vectors in terms of other
vectors so that's that's something that
has to stop at some point we have the
same issue in with with vectors as lists
of numbers in the world for language in
general so we'll have a representation
of the abstract II 1 detector right
right right right
but I mean ok right but fine
this is also by the way the ordering
here from 0 0 to 1 1 is that forced by
something or is that arbitrary because
for example our boolean functions are
ordered the other way round
so in other words if I say something
like you know if I do you know my
favorite you know some something like
this whatever I mean let's say something
like that right that's the way round
it's ordered so what determines this
ordering in this case that's just the
conventional bordering that's used in
the quantum information community yeah I
think it's out there of 0 1 0 1 exactly
ok well it's a little bit funky because
it's the opposite way around for the way
our boolean functions work so we can do
some thinking about that but let's not
get stuck on that particular issue right
now so you mean that in general we sort
through before for something that is
correct
see yeah because because that means I
label a boolean function if I say
boolean function of I don't know 7 or
something
a bee oh great well anyway this this
will have I think I can do a truth table
con time yes I mean what's it called um
yeah William table just brilliant
does it do it even without yeah okay
okay what does that mean anyway
I'm now confused by what that actually
means um well can you use and or
something yeah well that's not going
because it's commutative so I think that
the issue here is you were doing two
variables right yeah that's I mean you
see the ordering there I think that's
the seven that's the case that's boolean
function of seven is that so in other
words if we are using a boolean function
to represent some you know to convert
that to some quantum function it's going
to end up the wrong way around
okay so Hosea I can do some thinking
about that I'm after this okay fine all
right I'm just flagging that point okay
but that's not the most okay is the way
that you're representing you know this
whole planet states thing and so on and
the question of whether okay so Michaels
raised the question is quantum discrete
state the right name and your argument I
mean if I were to add a w-4 here that
was some completely unrelated thing your
argument Michael is what about well my
argument is that the naming this great
state is very rarely used I think most
people would call it a state of a finite
dimensional quantum systems right
there's nothing discrete about the state
the state is still continuously
parameters it's the demint
the embedding system that makes it
discrete in this sense okay so you don't
like the word discrete no at least not
in this usage I don't like it because
you think because it's finite
dimensional as in it's got perfectly
good real numbers complex numbers in
these state vectors and things but it is
it is fire see many basis vectors I mean
what is it it's really a finite system
it's a quantum finite quantum system is
that right a quantum finite system well
but as a system to be finite what do you
mean by this place I mean it isn't a
field
it's called only finitely many degrees
of freedom but harmonic oscillators also
not afeared yet it would not fall under
this how would one represent okay so
what like solutions solutions to the
Challenger equation you know with so
you're saying ok so what is the
hierarchy here so it's these things
which have qubits and so on which are
discrete you know spin up spin down type
things then we've got things like
solutions to the Schrodinger equation if
I'm not mistaken that right I mean you
know you know - the space continuous
differential equation yes uhm we have
infinite tens of products of this finite
dimension once we know like spin system
I think yeah okay right and then we have
infinite products of of continuous
systems ok ok and so the analogy of that
with our other kinds of systems is what
is the analogy so we've got you know
discrete lists of we've got lists of
discrete well ok so nothing here is at
the lowest level discrete except for the
fact that the number of degrees of
freedom is is finite yep and the
representation of what's going on is
just numbers as opposed to functions
like functions they could have follow
measles yeah okay but they don't have
spatial extent for example boy there's
no space available we were to extend
this to include those kinds of things
what would be involved what would it
then look like what would things start
to look like then in a in a Heisenberg
whew this vectors would become
infinitely long well by the Heisenberg
view you mean where the where the state
vectors are evolving as opposed to the
operators no I mean matrix mechanics
builders reading us faithful
oh I see I see I see I see ok right fine
but I see
but then ok but then if we look at the
transition to quantum field theory where
we where basically we're looking at s
matrices and so on those is the S matrix
the generalization of the of the thing
you're describing there I mean it's the
operator that acts on those infinite
dimensional vectors is that right or am
i confuse I think there's one more step
in between so I think the first step is
here we have a finite dimensional vector
space in which this all lives the qubits
lives just in in situ so then we make it
infinite I mentioned that one to
represent a function like a harmonic
oscillator function then we need a fork
space of infinitely many of them to
represent the field and then we have
asthmatics
okay I understand
so okay so your issue here huh sigh okay
what would this look like if we were
going to have a spatially extended thing
I mean in current quantum computing
people I mean like for example in in
standard computation we you know we
think we're dealing with bits and we
don't discuss any kind of spatial extent
of bits in some kind of analog computing
thing we might but what walk me through
what we would do if we were generalizing
this framework to deal with sort of
standard Schrodinger equation type
things like for example when we need to
do our stuff with molecules is there a
way what what would we ultimately do to
represent you know the water molecule
for example this one I feel like I said
a little bit of simpler things because
we would only be interested in a
precision representation of the wave
form which would make it much easier
here we want to represent in the way
that we can go to any basis like already
only few people already look at the
momentum distribution of water molecule
not to speak about any more bizarre yeah
well so you're saying you're saying we
can lock the in this case we're allowing
an arbitrary basis in the case of
typical quantum chemistry we're locking
it down to some kind of position I think
so but the main change I think would be
changing from vector based description
to a function based description yeah and
and there is no nice connection like we
don't have any way of going from our
lists of numbers to our functions mm-hmm
and yeah that's why from the beginning
we have tried to restrict to the what we
call the discrete case but Michael is
right the proper name is finite
dimensional it has to be a whole world
but finite that doesn't sorry for finite
you know what I mean special
right but I mean then this becomes in
the case where we've got some instead of
those discrete degrees of freedom there
we instead have something which is a you
know an arbitrary position is that right
we have a degree of freedom there that I
mean that right there is three degrees
of freedom each of which or am i
confused here yeah yeah okay so it's
that left hand side that somehow becomes
more elaborate but a lot more elaborate
it's not just changing we have to change
that list of three numbers by a function
at the point of restricting yourself to
these finite dimensional systems is that
for quantum computing that's all it's
ever used it so far and I know I hate to
do this again I think it might be wise
for us to move on and then Michael we
can again have a discussion okay just
the name I feel I'm bothered by aspect
to the functionality okay so I mean this
way of just saying this is what it is
and that's the state it's in there's a
little weird to me and we're not even
documenting that are we mmm
so if you look at the other examples
down further there's a lot of other
examples like that and we didn't want to
put you know like a hundred things in
the documentation we thought the
examples was the better place no that's
not right
you have to have it all in the
documentation it has to be all listed in
the documentation okay
yeah I think I share that that feeling
of right now we are packing too many
things into the constructor and and my
main worry is when we go symbolic when
users say I have a state as one another
as to and they don't say anything about
them
so these doesn't feel very well right
now how does that work how would you
construct any and then they want a
product state of those two exactly so in
the same way that we have now say tensor
product and we have tensor product of v1
and v2 and that's fine it's just there
waiting for users to to change leave one
by a list and be to another list thinks
of that so we may go that route but and
I'm not sure how many symbols we would
be forced and whether we can't reuse
tensor product for here well I mean is
it the case that this w1 w2 w3 is in
fact alternatively described as a tensor
product no it's only described in this
case where it's a basis state so some of
them it's a tensor product is a woman
isn't right right and that's what led us
to this design in the first place and
going back up here this product thing
I'm now totally confused so this is
you've got to be able you've got to
write out what the possible forms of
vowels actually is in the details there
um okay and okay so this case is this is
a five plus state whatever that might
mean
that's what if there are ball States so
it's an entangled state okay fine what's
this that's one of the things in the
documentation above where it basically
says you take a quantum state that
you've defined and you're tracing out a
subsystem to give you a smaller quantum
state
yeah I looked at this one earlier I
think it's nice functionality definitely
needed but I would also come from the
outside operating on it so we also have
a function we didn't know whether we
would want it or not whether we want to
use it like this or and the regular
function but it's called quantum partial
trace or quantum partial TR and it
performs that functionality so you don't
actually need to do it internally like
that we just had both options at the
moment for whichever one was preferred
well so these are quantum operations
these are quantum state operations or
something as opposed to whatever this is
these things like products and so on you
could imagine having them on the outside
where these things are called something
like I mean maybe I'm wrong about this
quantum state operation I mean if we
want it to save on product and then that
in turn you know something like this
that crazy okay I like what do you think
about that as you seem fine to me okay
so that then that gets us out of this
weird situation here okay so I that
that's easy to do I can do that in a
problem okay all right let's keep
looking at some more of these things
here so then I get it those are by the
way there's something wrong with this
formatting this for hunting is really
weird looking and this is just
formatting that I came up with on my own
I don't have the background and design
so I'm just I guess what I'm saying is
when we represent a quantum discrete
state what do we want to know I mean
this isn't the objects kind of the
left-hand-side thing because it's the
left hand side thing in the in the
definition of the quantum discrete state
and then the right name of the object
that's not the state of the object you
have an electron named Yvonne that isn't
isn't a state okay
but that's you can also expand it and
see what other things we have okay but
in an alternative name here of quantum
finite system for example um let's
imagine that this was called quantum
finite system no I don't think so that's
a bad name because we don't represent a
system we represent the state we believe
a system is in no but there are systems
that behave quantum mechanically in
those take a state in some Hilbert space
but we don't but we don't have the level
of representing the system symbolically
yeah I agree with Michael here we have
to spread the states of a system of
marrascaud okay so what okay so we've
got quantum discrete state quantum
finite state whatever the heck that
means I don't know I mean you're saying
the full correct name is quantum finite
dimensional finite dimension a quantum
state would be my default one I know
it's a bit off if I knocked
quantum state well it will be really
nice to start with the word quantum
quantum finite dimensional state we have
a couple of suggestions here from the
live stream
somebody just suggests in quantum state
I think that's and things like list
quantum state I think that's gonna get
super confusing um
quantum states cells can't you have a
standard constructor and specify an
alternative basis by optionally saying
basis error whatever a finite system
would be a quantum cell I have not heard
of quantum cells anybody here heard of
quantum cells no in weak nor face based
representations I see which we're not
doing here this is this is not I mean
that's that's in the world of yes and no
but if you don't have finite dimension
realizations of the canonical
commutation relations which Venus
construction we have the newest one we
can get so we can build the nearest
equivalents of weakness for finite
dimensional system okay somebody is
suggesting the word construct always a
word we which which is which is
ambiguous yes it is it is multiplied
ambiguous not least because you can
either read this construct or construct
and it kind of I think goes downhill
from there but but look let's okay so
what you're saying is quantum finite
dimensional state is the then what he
would you propose for the quantum
discreet operation thing
by which access a this one can be a
quantum operation because whatever we
say what is the concrete operation would
make it clear when it acts on a quantum
state if it acts in a discrete or
continuous fashion okay
there might be no need to differentiate
X petit between the discrete and all the
world all right well let's keep going
here with with this rather ponderous
quantum fine a dimensional state um so I
like the UM quantum state operation
product Trace all of that stuff then
what that what you should guessed it I
think if we want to look at quantum
discrete operation and then actually
quantum measurement distribution I think
those might be useful because I tried to
implement a lot of the stuff that you
would mentioned previously okay let's
take a look okay
so here instead of before where I had
quantum discrete operations and I just
had the unitary ones and then we had
bringt symbols for observables and pob
ends and all of these things I took your
advice and tried to put it all in in one
format and you can just specify the type
of operation you want okay so in this
way you're just everything is just at
some quantum discreet operation and your
circuit just consists of a bunch of
quantum discrete operations not you know
discrete operations and you know
observables and POV ends and other
things let me take a look at what some
of these are okay quantum discreet
operation
unitary and what's the and the W is what
this is acting on yep
it's a little funky that you have to put
what it's acting on so deep inside the
operation itself I mean it will be like
having to say you know this squaring
this function function is specifically
operating on this element of an
association that seems unfortunately you
have to say what its operating on inside
it here right so that's one thing one of
the two things that we wanted to talk
about today is a functional
representation essentially what you're
saying right now where you don't have to
specify when you create the operation
yep and I have some ideas for that but I
want to formalize them first well let's
let's okay all right fine so that seems
wrong to me this this should be a pure
function thing without saying what it's
applying itself to so these operations
don't if I'm not mistaken they they are
applying themselves to well well how
many degrees of freedom could be in here
could there be multiple degrees of
freedom that are in the same that this
operation is essentially a 2-legged
operation that's applied to two degrees
of freedom or just always to one it can
be - right you can have as many as you
want actually um so these the already
created gates that are like internal in
this package are go up to having three
cubits okay fine so a typical
controlled-not gate or something right i
don't understand why it isn't a
functional representation already i mean
in other words yep that's something that
i mean that was on the list that's
something that will get done okay but
but hold on so
this here okay so the condition here
would surely be in most cases a pure
function that applies to yeah I'm
completely confused why that why I mean
it seems to me that this this form here
should be instead let's say it's quantum
operation unitary arrow controlled-not
or something and then that simply acts
on this that right
so one of the problems that we had with
that is because the operation itself has
properties that we wanted to be able to
extract and we thought it was it
wouldn't really work to be able to be
having the brackets the quantum object
and also bracket the property and also
the other problem is that that this is
ultimately going to be applied to a
quantum finite dimensional state exactly
and so that's that's why we decided on
this type of representation but I was I
had some ideas for how to do it
functionally easier ideas there on the
the other computer unfortunately because
the lost computer but do you did are
they also in your brain or can you say
something about them I can email them to
you guys after I I don't want to waste
our time trying to reconstruct it so can
we use W in the second argument here
like acting on this state comma W like
when we say do something on this
polynomial comma X yeah I understand
that makes it quite a bit of sense but
what we what we're then missing is the
ability to extract properties from this
quantum you know operation and that's
why in some cases you know that's why we
end up with things like classifier
information and so on rather than you
know because the classifier itself is
acting on actual data so what kinds of
properties of the quantum operation
which sadly are not documented here but
what kind of operations you can go down
and you can get out the matrix
representation the inputs the the q2
dimension things like that okay
humph well I mean we actually have this
general information function I mean
sadly it's sort of a pun rather relative
to quantum information but forget that
um we could call it data or value we
have examples of other cases yes but I
mean it's an extractor function that
extracts essentially information from
this from the operator here and then
yeah I mean I think this is an
interesting idea to think of these
things like the I mean they are markers
in the same way that x and y in a
polynomial our kind of markers you could
you could the polynomial could be turned
into a a pure anonymous function but in
fact you're using x and y to indicate
where certain you know data goes and you
could argue that the same thing is
what's going on here is that a fair
argument yeah I like this construction
so I think this is good and I'm glad
that we were able to get to this point
okay let's look at quantum finite
dimensional state and how that relates
to this as well because what that's
saying is see there what is the analog I
mean
if this is our polynomial okay and this
is saying we're in the polynomial to go
looking um this thing here instead of
naming like w1 we would just put like
your hatch 1 or something there um an
even better analogy might be potential
on it's illnesses because it's discrete
and I think these dollars are acting
like indices actually
I'm sorry so you're saying it's like an
association like having an association
here or something not so much an
association but but the indices of a
tensor like going to say is matrix IJ so
this is like high J and J which is then
what like a sparse array type thing
no so we can describe position this
indices positionally like the first
index or the second index well we can
give them names and then things like
transpositions is just exchange I and J
I think said that so I think this is
more like this use of indices
internships okay but then what are you
proposing that there be a mechanism you
know the one mechanism here would be
that this could be a pure list of values
so this could be so that the effective
default name of the first degree of
freedom is just one that we could have
something like this but
one degree of freedom whose name is one
but how in general would you be able to
specify and it's okay one of the
arguments that I had before is the
officer I guess it's an option in the
quantum finite dimensional States is a
QT dimension which allows you to
basically from the cuted dimension you'd
be able to infer given what you just put
and things of that nature how many slots
you have what do you mean by how many
slots I mean that this look if I had so
if you just put in a numerical array
then in your numerical array had force
you know was a list I see then it's a
two then it's an acute dimension is 2
then you're saying that that implies
that that is just the the unrolling of a
2 by 2 thing right exactly whereas it's
unrolled is kind of unfortunate but I
mean I certainly it's a convention in
this business and we have to do some
unrolling in order to be able to
differentiate between states of higher
dimensions or just entangled states that
have multiple quantum objects inside yes
and also if we're gonna use any kind of
matrix formulas and we'd better
unraveled like that otherwise we're not
using matrices we're using some kind of
higher dimensional tensor if I'm not
mistaken no words if you want to make if
the quantum operation is going to be
represented by a matrix
you've got to unroll like that is it
completely obvious that one should be
representing it by a vector and that
that that isn't just some convenience
for hand calculation or some weird thing
like that I think it it makes sense to
do it this way um
so Jose and I had thought about this a
fair amount and I mean we can go back to
the drawing board and look at it again
let me just understand it so the
formalism of quantum mechanics is is in
terms of matrices has been for a hundred
years
right um the the question here is if
you've got
a direct products the outer product
state you know let's say it's a it's a
collection of three q3 two-bit two three
you know standard binary qubits okay
then one way to represent that would be
as a rank three tensor if I'm not
mistaken right okay
but now operating on that rank three
tensor you would then end up with you
know for us right now let's imagine that
you had I don't know how many how many
let's say a controlled not gate has two
inputs so let's say well what's a the
like a tough League eight or something
has three problems yeah totally
do H Fred game any of those all my
friends all have three input gates how
nice um okay so okay so imagine a tough
League eight for example okay um and its
operating its acting on this rank three
tensor what is then the form of that
gate what does that gate I mean normally
it will be up acting on the unravelled
you know one one one one going down to
zero zero zero or the other way around
you know length eight vector right it
will be an eight by eight matrix acting
on a length eight vector if I'm not
mistaken correct whereas in the other
sense it would be you know as you're
saying a rank three tenths are acting on
it isn't a rank three tensor it's around
three tensor is the thing it's acting on
it was a racist answer then is it yeah
is it a ranks extensor that returns
another rank three tensor yeah okay is
that obviously completely stupid I mean
what what form does it have as a rank
six tensor is it nice and
if you were to take that rag 6/10 sir is
it purely is the natural ranks extensor
related by array flattened to the you
know rank to 8x8 matrix it's related by
flattening and transpositions but it's
just more difficult for the user to have
to input something like that I'm not
completely convinced
so in this happens also with tensor
product and Kronecker product it's
basically two different communities that
are more used to only matrices or tensor
so for deterrant explain that I mean so
yes so we get frequently comments from
people saying oh why am I doing this
tensor product am I getting something so
deep when I want is just a matrix and
the answer is always the same you
shouldn't use tensor product use
chronica product and then everybody's
coming but there's a tensor product
followed by a ray flatten yes it is but
some people are very feel very
uncomfortable using higher depths yes I
understand that but the advantage here
is that if one did it that way I mean
maybe I'm not thinking about this
correctly but isn't it the case then
that you know right now we have integer
indices but we could imagine having at
every level having for example I I see I
mean this is hurried function if in the
case where it's a function of three if
we were looking at shorter equation
stuff we would end up with some weird
curried function of three three level
curried function to represent the
positions of three particles got go
ahead Michael I think it's the same what
Jose truss said it depends on the
community in the cranium computing area
people like it trusts as a vector but
people who give the spin systems they
definitely prefer the tensor product
lovely ok so I only have another ten
minutes before it's TA okay um and we
have another meeting also here I think
we should wrap for right now on that do
you want to just very very quickly look
at the quantum measurement distribution
that'll take just a minute other types
of operations like boolean functions why
I just described an issue with boolean
functions because right there's another
issue with boolean functions in that in
general boolean functions are not
invertible
where as in you know in quantum we a
very small fraction of boolean functions
are invertible right many right and so
it was one of the questions with whether
we want to restrict ourselves to
invertible because those are the only
ones that are by themselves quantum
friendly or we want to allow all boolean
functions and then convert them into you
quantum acceptable I don't know how you
would do that well there there's a way
to convert them into circuits into
quantum circuits that are just you know
a bunch of unitary operations and then
measurements but it gets very messy what
what about I mean if you apply I'm a
little confused here if you if you take
a pure state and you apply one of these
information destroying functions to it
don't you get a mixed state
so what would be an example of that
raising things out what's that facing
things out yeah I mean don't you if you
take two cubits and you end them not any
kind of controlled you know quantum and
you just and them the ordinary way I
believe that you simply get a mixed
state out operation all right what you
can do is you can perform a like a
controlled-not operation on some extra
wire oh just you know we call it and
Siletz and then you reverse all the
intermediate computation status so that
it's as if you had a NAND gate am I
simply wrong that you got a mixed state
out from the thing I described yes
because like everything is unitary okay
you send the operation so you can't
represent the non unitary operation as
your point Michael isn't it nonunitary
you can implement things like the and
gate the analog of that in quantum by
using some combination of unitary
operations and measurements I see but
but so and then what would you get out
you'll get out something in the
classical limit or is there a classical
in the classical is there a classical
analog or is there no classical analog I
don't think there's a classical analog
here so what is the relationship between
the quantum the puffed out you know
quantum and and the non quantum and so
the quantum end is just a the circuit is
completely reversible up until
measurements that it's the only
difference so it's just decomposed it's
just a matrix decomposition essentially
okay let's look at this last thing here
and then we've all got to go for this
meeting so what is this now so instead
of just having measurements we keep
everything in terms of some more
symbolic pool yeah and then you can
perform all of the you know general
distribution that's cool so that's
seriously cool does it work
yep hmm so in other words what you're
saying is
that yeah this is cool this is that this
is a packaging so so the thing you
should show okay what about things like
the coach inspector theorem and things
like can't you can't you represent given
that you have this distribution can't
you represent all those kinds of funky
combinations and measurements and things
that way
coach inspector it's one of the it's a
sort of it's a it's a fancier thing than
bells inequality now it's the poof of
context reality it's not enough to
measure and operator you always need for
every proper measurement a complete set
of commuting operator so that all t
generate eigenspaces are totally the
sources but but my question is in terms
of this representation can I get to see
all of that in a cool way using this
quantum measurement distribution or am I
going is that the wrong direction
shouldn't I be able to see all these
various bells inequality ish from this
quantum measurement distribution I think
so no I don't think so
because it like parent is not
represented in the distribution no I
understand in the correlation between
individual results no I understand that
but what I'm saying is that this
distribution is this is the this is the
classical version and then the whole
point would be well let's see that you
should still be able to get a joint
distribution out now I'm getting myself
very confused because I know that you
can't get a joint distribution out
because that's the whole point of bells
inequality you can still form
expectation values yes you can but and
this is and so this is the expectation
value is that right but then you can
then you're taking the expectation value
of this again I'm so now I'm confused um
or
unfortunately we have to wrap for right
now we clearly have quite a bit more I
think we have at least two more hours of
going over this to do we're making
progress yes but I think it'd be useful
to get in the documentation here to
really list out all those different
cases and write possible um things up
there in that documentation I think it
would also be useful to start getting
together a guide page that lists all
these various functions okay and I don't
know what a super operator is here
that's like it's basically you can
operate on your quantum state from both
sides like left and right matrix
multiplications okay um yeah we have had
an increasing number of contacts from
the the people who say they have quantum
computers and are offering various kinds
of api's and so on so I think it would
be worthwhile um after we do one or two
more iterations on this to get a meeting
with either sequentially with several of
those groups or together with with all
of those groups to go over what we um
you know what we're doing here wonderful
okay well we have to I guess
partnerships has to communicate with
these guys maybe we should try doing a
couple of them separately before we do a
big one with everybody together or we'll
end up with some kind of we'll end up
with having to explain basic things to a
large collection of people which will be
annoying all right um okay so are we are
we going to be able to follow up like
let's say this week on on more you know
let's do the next iteration of this if
we can this week um and um okay
anything else
I think that's it okay thanks a lot see
you later bye